[Music]  [Music]  you're after something  [Music]  is it revenge  money  or is it something else you look good  little rough around the edges but good  heard about a job big shot gangster  putting together crew  I'm a driver and I'm a flier  the waited a long time for a shot like  this  or did sir  well what do you know you got a line on  a ship  yeah no guy he's the best smuggler  around I heard a story about you I was  wondering if it's true everything you've  heard about me it's true l-3 let's go  with a mean man's face oh these guys  if you come with us you're in this life  for good  my wanna buckle up baby  [Music]  let me give you some advice  assume everyone will betray you and  you'll never be disappointed I got a  really good feeling about this  when do you know how to fly a hundred  and ninety years old feel great  [Music]  [Music]  you